رئيس بيلاروسيا يلوح باستخدام السلاح
النووي يقول انه لن يتردد في ذلك اذا
تعرضت بلاده لاي اعتداء قبل ايام استقبله
الرئيس الروسي في منتجع السوتشي واعلن ان
البنيه التحتيه لتخزينها للاسلحه النوويه
التكتيكيه في بيلاروسيا ستصبح جاهزه في
السابع من الشهر القادم لتنقل الاسلحه بعد
ذلك بقليل تستخدم الاسلحه النوويه
التكتيكيه لتدمير التشكيلات العسكريه
والاسلحه في ارض المعركه مداها قصير نسبيا
وقوتها النوويه اقل بكثير من الرؤوس
النوويه التي توضع على الصواريخ الباليسيه
تعتقد الحكومه الامريكيه ان روسيا تملك
الفي سلاح نووي تكتيكي ينظر الغرب لنقل
هذه الاسلحه الى بيلاروسيا كتهديد النووي
روسي ليس لاوكرانيا وحدها ولكن لكل اوروبا
لكن روسيا ايضا تتهم الغرب باستخدام
النووي في حرب اوكرانيا تشير موسكو الى مد
دول اوكرانيا بذخائر اليورانيوم المنظف
ويلوح الرئيس بوتين باستخدامها اذا استدعت
الضروره ردا على استخدامها ضد قواته صحيفه
عن استعداد البيت الابيض لمد اوكرانيا
بهذه الذخائر ونقلت عن مسؤول امريكي ان
البانتاجون يريد تسليمها مع دبابات ابرمس
استخدام اليورانيوم المنظم في هذه الذخائر
يمكن من اختراق الدبابات والدروع بسهوله
اكبر حيث تصطدم قذيفه اليورانيوم المنظف
بالهدف لتحترق ذاتيا في درجه حراره عاليه
تنبعث معها جزيئات اليورانيوم متناهيه
الصغر في الغلاف الجوي ويستخدم اليورانيوم
المنظم في القذائف التي تطلق من دبابات
تشالنجر البريطانيه وابرز الامريكيه
الى الالمانيه انتقدت موسكو بشده تقديم
بريطانيا هذه الدخائر الى اوكرانيا مع
شحنه دبابات تشالنجر اثنين اعتبرت لندن
حديثه موسكو عن سلاح نووي تضليلا وفقا
لمعهد الامم المتحده لبحوث نزع السلاح لا
يمكن اعتبار ذخيره اليورانيوم المنظم
اسلحه نوويه لانه لا يولد تفاعلا نوويا
ولا يدخل تحت التعريف القانوني للاسلحه
النوويه لكن خبراء البيئه والصحه العامه
يرون انه يمكن ان يؤدي الى حساسيه في
الجلد وفشل الكلى ويزيد من مخاطر الاصابه
بالسرطان اذا مع انطلاق الهجوم الاوكراني
المضاد يعود سجال السلاح النووي الذي يبقى
حتى الان ورقه للضغط